they're protesting because they're stuck
African migrants who've made a dangerous
journey over thousands of kilometres up
through Latin America in the hope of
reaching the US but instead they've
ended up here in Taba chula South met
scope the Mexican government wary of
incurring the wrath of American
president Donald Trump won't let them
cross the country to get to the US
border and is only prepared to let them
leave by the South back to Guatemala so
for the last four months around a
thousand people have camped around the
gates of the titular migrant detention
center in limbo look at the conditions
here it rains every day were camped
amidst the water the authorities haven't
told us anything
we're being dehumanized this bottlenecks
been caused by a change of policy in
Mexico before they give Asian and
African migrants permissions across the
country and leave by whichever border
they could including the u.s. one but
with the pressure from the states that's
ended and with it the hopes of those
like seventeen year old Rousseff that's
not his real name who thought he was
almost there like many he came in
through Brazil where these are
requirements amid the lawless jungle
between Colombia and Panama he lost his
father he's frightened to show his
identity he says that as a leader he's
under watch
but the authorities have tolerated the
presence of the camp there have been
occasional brushes
Mexico's offering them the chance of
asylum but that process is long and
uncertain in Capitola the queue for
applicants goes around the block most
here anyway say that's not what they
want they feel if they can just hold out
they'll eventually get through
given the current position of both
Mexico and the u.s. that seems very
unlikely John Holman al-jazeera tappet
una